2011 gegen das große rätselraten los ein
schatzsucher team hatte ein
geheimnisvolles riesiges objekt auf dem
meeresboden zwischen schweden und
finnland in der ostsee entdeckt sein
geschätzter durchmesser 60 meter und es
ranken sich viele mysteriöse theorien um
das angeblich versteinerte ufo das dem
rasen im falken von star wars ziemlich
allen soll ist diese sogenannte ostsee
anomalie tatsächlich bereits 140 1000
jahre alt und besteht aus materialien
die es hier in der natur gar nicht gibt
also fragen über fragen und die
antworten die gibt es jetzt wirklich zum
science fiction
herzlich willkommen zur blick zum und
was soll ich sagen wieder einen
themenvorschlag von whatsapp fest steht
in der baltischen see nördlich der
schwedischen insel irland liegt in einer
tiefe von etwa 80 metern ein
gigantisches kreisrundes objekt das hat
ein schwedisches schatzsucher das ocean
tj maxx im juni 2011 entdeckt und weil
sie nicht wussten was das rätselhafte
objekt wirklich darstellt nannten sie es
ostsee anomalie ein ferngesteuertes auto
und machte später bilder mit einer
unterwasserkamera und mehr details
kommen ans licht das objekt scheint zu
sein also wirklich kreisrund allerdings
mit einem 90 grad winkel und an einer
stelle scheint man sogar eine zu
erkennen obendrauf befindet sich eine
art kuppel ja ihr könnt euch vorstellen
dass müsst ihr die fans esoteriker und
verschwörungstheoretiker ausflippen als
sie diese ergebnisse auf einer
pressekonferenz vorstellte noch das team
der schatzsucher betonte schon damals
dass sie keine ahnung hätten was sie
dort gefunden hatten keineswegs bestand
das team darauf dass es sich um ein ufo
handel doch das macht die ufo gemeinde
noch hellhöriger genauso wie die aussage
der schatzsucher dass ihre instrumente
in der nähe der ostsee anomalie verrückt
spielen würden die spekulation ging in
alle möglichen richtungen ein ufo ein
akt eine uralte zivilisationen oder
hinweise auf atlantis aber auch die star
wars fans waren außer sich um glaubten
an ein millenium fig hatte han solos
raumfrachter etwa einen unfall gab nun
war trotz seines über raum antriebs in
der ostsee gestrandet doch die bilder
der unterwasserkamera waren eher
verschwommen und unscharf und ließen
eine genaue analyse nicht zu es gab
spekulationen über eine art pfeiler die
verschwörungstheoretiker auf den bildern
entdeckt haben wollten so
hundertprozentiger sicherheit konnte die
ostsee anomalie tatsächlich bis heute
nicht identifiziert werden denn das
ginge nur mit einer sehr kostspieligen
unterwasser expedition jeweiligen seiten
im internet wird auch taucher verwiesen
die mai 2017 proben von der ostsee
anomalie bergen analysieren konnten mit
einem spektakulären ergebnis demnach
enthält enthalten die proben metalle die
die natur setzt sich reproduzieren kann
auch diese expedition habe außerdem
gezeigt dass alle elektronischen geräte
in der nähe des tatorts versagen
die anhänger der sogenannten and aliens
also der altertümlichen aliens eine
unterabteilung der ufo fangemeinde quasi
glauben fest daran dass aliens die erde
vor langer zeit besucht haben
von zehntausenden von jahren hätte der
außerirdischen besuch der menschheit
überhaupt erst ermöglicht sich weiter zu
entwickeln doch was sagen seriöse
forschungsteams zu diesem ganzen ja
studien ganzen spekulationen eine
außerirdische sensation können
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ausschließen
bei dem gestein handelt es sich wohl um
basalt also vulkanischen ursprungs und
das würde zusammenpassen mit der
entstehungsgeschichte der gesamten nord
baltischen region denn hier haben vor
allem gletscher prozesse eine große
rolle gespielt konkret vermuten
forschungsteams hier so genannte drops
ton steine sind wohl von den
schmelzenden als scheuen gefallen und
auf den meeresgrund gesunken
möglicherweise könnte es sich auch um
einen vulkankrater halten denn auch die
schatzsucher selbst sind mittlerweile
der meinung dass es sich bei der ostsee
anomalie wohl um mineralisches um ein
mineralisches gebilde handelt ja also
wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollte
die youtube autobots funktioniert ja
nicht richtig dann endet mich bei
whatsapp nur dann verpasst er kein video
und über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich und garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken es gibt auch mit anderen
messen john und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es im neuesten video
um den prozess über den volks lehrer
hier auf youtube der ja die ein oder
andere verschwörungstheorie hier
verbreitet dafür hier draufklicken aber
nicht die genau locker vergessen und
hier geht es war damit dafür auch
draufklicken ufo-sichtungen da geht es
um die staatliche ufo forschung in den
usa bis dann bleibt dran